ya trois ans l'un des meilleurs jeux
d'horreur de tous les deux arrivés entre
nos mains
moi
en classe un bon jour donné sur la
demande et aux classes de allez c'est
parti
implied des mots [ __ ] je suis tout
excité comme une puce bienvenue dans la
démo de classe 2 vous êtes blackline
german un cameraman qui travaillaient
pour sa femme line vous êtes tous les
deux journalistes et vous fait des
investigations sur des histoires que
personne n'ose approchez vous suivez une
piste indices vous menant à l'assassinât
impossible d'une femme enceinte qui
s'appelle jean de l'enquète vous amener
bien profond dans le désert d'arizona
dans une obscurité si profonde que
personne n'y voit de lumière et une
corruption tellement présente que le
seul truc à faire est de devenir fou
d'accord parfait barcelonais en
confiance ok c'est parti hop [ __ ]
j'attends ça depuis tellement d'années
je suis très content ok fait chaud des
lunettes le mec qui tombe tout temps ok
il a repris ses lunettes parfait moi je
suis blessé non ça va je peux bouger
il ya juste un peu mal à la tête j'ai ma
caméra ça c'est quand même la base
[ __ ] mais qu on gagne et on y fait
quoi quand tu arrives à auribeau dette
et la maison de vacances où tous les
mecs en vacances se font assassiner sur
x pour sauter ok bien évidemment appuyé
circuit pour prendre la pelle et tuer le
méchant et finale en place de m [ __ ]
ils ont condamné les fenêtres et oups ne
font pas et là dedans allez on continue
moi jamais trop prudent bon ya du bruit
bah ça devait être mais pas aux [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] bombay couilles ah mais non
mais encore l'histoire de batterie avec
des piles rats les [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
mais c'est quoi mext endroits non
oh oh ah c'est mon nom c'est bon non
[ __ ] ça crie partout en baisse et des
iso is to hide ménard je me cachais dans
le bidon la gâchette bidon quoi c'est
gratuit à l'accord au québec il est plus
la main d'un sa fin mais je saurai on
serait qu'on pourrait se cacher dans les
bidons ok ok ok je me cachais dans le
seau éventuellement non que les bidons
kevin on sait quoi je vais toqué aopen
windows lequel veut mourir j'ai vu un
mec
oh [ __ ] hockey hop ça pour que ses
portes claquent il arrive il ya des
bruits des bruits à des bruits des
bruits faut que jean bart faut que je me
bats ya des bruits et un mec est un mec
annoncé cette [ __ ] de portes qui
claquent
j'ai eu tellement peur ok on y va oh
[ __ ] ça cimetière situé gens qui sont
morts avant moi c'est ça je dis je serai
pas de batterie on regardera la batterie
pour les situations de crise à défaut il
faut qu'on soit bien organisé
ok j'avoue je craque [ __ ] mais mais
qu'on voit carrément rien on voit rien
je vois rien mais là c'est du sens c'est
du sang avec des peluches mais non
respectueux des enfants quand même à
imaginer
j'ose même pas imaginer ce cas là dedans
vague pour qu'ils retournent mouches se
sentir le cadavre
qu'est ce qu'on a ici ok ah bah voilà
bah voilà mec mais c'est des enfants ok
vous continuez c'est par là on monte on
arrive sur un cheval qui bouge tout seul
c'est parfait ya quelqu'un dans le pays
ouais on va me pousser dedans ont même
poussé dedans c'est sûr
la joie calamars ok on a des dents puis
caméras caméras vite cédé conduit
toulouse biolay l'ain pourquoi est ce
qu'il faudrait que j'allais un mois non
non tu vas pas besoin et pas ailleurs
pas besoin c'est toi femme tu va énervé
le monstre appelé 28 aussi kit est morte
autant pâtir et les automnes sans valeur
je suis caché c'est tout mais y'a rien
dedans pas peine de regarder
[ __ ] à quoi j'ai atterri made en quoi
j'ai encore atterri comme et ses abats
ça va c'est plutôt rassurant c'est que
c'est la seule fois où j'ai rêvé qu'un
prof 10 sortez vos livres page 32
vraiment au nom mais mec comment même la
lumière de cette pièce devrait
clairement tu peux le couloir abusez pas
les gaillacois ces fermes et ça c'est
bien sûr là derrière c'est fermé c'est
fermé
bon bah non non non non si vous payez
rien là l allumer la lumière
tom elgar des réclamants qui rigole
colle à mon oreille [ __ ] mais mais
tout est fermé toutes les 100 % fermer
les yeux que je fasse je pourrais me
cacher au cash pour une telle chance
d'un casier c'est sûr ça j'ai cru au que
j'ai cru voir un truc est pourrave mais
ces mecs n'importe quoi arrêtez arrêtez
pas il ya bientôt arrêter les cases il a
suffi de batterie de mourir j'aimerais
faut que je reparte là dedans ce sujet
maurice est fermé mais chez toi tu
voterais non mais tu te fais mené au
deuxième but un bon mec
ok bon fidèle supporter s'est ouvert
j'ai eu trop de chats tg puis aller
dedans
voilà mourir dans la vraie vie imagine
imagine j'entends des bruits bizarres
chez moi et ma copine veut que j'aille
voir ce qui se passe mais je mets ses
mots et je la prends comme ça je la met
en boule et je l'envoie dans la pièce en
question est celle qui va investir d'ici
à vingt ans qu'elle arrête sa première
ag sicard revient la bomba revient pas
attendez c'est quoi ce monde mec c'est
trop bizarre je pense que j'y passe en
dessous au courant pas il est là le truc
il a indiqué derrière des sortes de main
j'étais moins qui sortent de là bas je
me faire attraper mais qu il faut y
aller je suis surpris y aller faut aller
à la porte qu'elle a
c'est
honte à coup sûr une maison trop bizarre
tellement belle que je cours je cours je
cours je cours je cours je croise trop
chaud qu'au cambodge aux hauts pétain au
[ __ ] attend on va on va remplir non
[ __ ] merdier un gars arrivent juste là
juste là ça va ça va ça va aller à
l'écart les [ __ ] en dépit le [ __ ]
follet aux [ __ ] sépare la regarder il
ya des trucs pour sauter dessus
non non non non non non non cette hausse
gb en courant je pense faut y aller en
cours actuel en courant j'y vais en
courant yes ben on va pas il mourra pas
il mourra pas moche moche mais c'est
quoi ça vous n'aurez jamais vous allez
produire sur place et a sorti sa sortie
ça allez allez allez pourquoi savez ça
c'est que je vais souffler ouais non non
non il ya d'autres mecs mais non non non
non non c'est bon de sortie [ __ ] mais
c'est plus tard de lunettes quoi il veut
pas l'aiguillé
cet hiver
ok ok je pose ça ici voilà il faut que
je change qui lie à sousse pantalon
qu'est-ce que ça pour ça on fera les
spéciales 2 c'est sûr et certain
mais c'était pas aimé la vidéo si vous
êtes chier dessus autant que moi est ce
screamer mec vraiment il m'a mis très
très très très mal jamais eu peur au
point de faire un cri aussi aiguë c'est
ouf
bordel vivement vivement versement
regarder vraiment très bonne démo merci
à la barre elle bondi du rêve à la
saison prochaine et 2 va bientôt la 24'
poker d'annalynne redescendre portez
vous bien john peace